hi there Steve Kaufman here um I got to
talk about patterns and language
learning and I think this is a very very
important point and it sort of was
triggered by the fact that i read an
article which and i will leave a link to
it here and I'll go into more detail at
my blog and I'll leave a link to my blog
as well in the description here and the
article was based on some research in in
Israel which showed that people who are
good at recognizing patterns in
mathematics will also be good in
wrecking in learning languages in other
words the ability to recognize patterns
not specifically language related
patterns but the ability to recognize
patterns is what makes people good
language learners and I was very happy
to read this because this is something
that I have felt intuitively for a long
long time and I think this is very
important for language learning you have
heard me some of you who have followed
my youtube channel for a while have
heard me express great skepticism with
regard to Noam Chomsky's universal
grammar I don't believe that we are born
with some Universal grammar and no
amount of explanation from linguistics
majors nor anything that i have read has
persuaded me otherwise I believed all
along that our brains are conceived or
have been developed to recognize
patterns and that's the main function of
the brain to recognize patterns to get
used to patterns so that we can lead our
lives more efficiently that the
experience that the brain has causes the
brain to establish certain pattern
certain linkages so that it's easier for
us to understand the world around us and
learning languages is no different now
this research seems to confirm that it's
our
ability to recognize patterns is the
ability of the brain to recognize
patterns so what does this mean for
language learning I have also felt when
it comes to language learning that
reading explanations of grammar had only
very minor had a minor influence on my
ability to to learn the language and to
get used to the patterns whereas if I
started to notice these patterns more
and more in my listening and reading
then my ability to understand the
language and also eventually to produce
the language improved but the key was
this ability to notice and I've talked a
lot about noticing how at first
everything is very fuzzy and as we nail
down a few things that we notice then
we're able to focus more on other things
and start to notice them as well but one
has to want to do it and we've always
I've often mentioned the people who live
in an environment like immigrants to
Canada who aren't very motivated to
learn who don't make an effort to try to
notice the patterns in the language
notice patterns of pronunciation
patterns of word usage and therefore
continue to make the same mistakes over
and over again I've talked about how
having other people correct you has
again in my opinion a minor impact on
our ability to learn because mostly we
have to train ourselves to recognize
patterns so I'm kind of normally I would
have waited till Friday to make another
video but I was so pleased to see this
article that I just had to make this
video here now and just further on the
subject of patterns I want to expand on
the experiment that I've had now with
Romanian where I wrote up about I don't
know 100 some odd 150 or so sentences
which I sort of divided into different
subject categories like sentences with
what than with when and with why and and
it seems and and there's a large number
of these potential subjects where you
can come up with 10 15 or more sample
sentences that correspond either to
cause an effect or purpose or
probability or any of these sort of
general concepts that we need to express
in all languages and I had in the case
of Romanian I had these translated into
Romanian had them recorded and I have
listened to them many many times and as
my ability to understand Romanian
improves and increases and as my
vocabulary increases and I can listen to
interesting content on history and the
news and so forth from Radio Romania I
still regularly go back and listen to
these basic phrases because I think it
is important to have a mixture of rich
interesting stimulating content which
has resonance which you're emotionally
you know connected with as you're
listening and some repetition of these
basic patterns so that again you notice
the more when you're listening and
reading so what I'm going to do at link
now I'm going to because we're
encouraging more interaction and mutual
help amongst our members and in fact
facilitating this that I'm going to try
to encourage our members to do the same
to come in there and create basic
pattern sentences whether it be in
Japanese or Russian or French or Spanish
or whatever language a great long list
of these divided by category you know
why because since when where and all
these sort of situations that you find
yourself in so that people can take the
ones that they're interested in and read
them at link link the words they need
listen to them while they're doing the
dishes and so forth and so on and I
wonder if those of you out there are
interested in helping out so again at my
blog I will publish a list of of the
categories I haven't published I'm not
going to put up all the sentences you
can go and find them at link the library
at link is free for anyone to go in and
download whatever they want you can
download we have these patterns sentence
now and
english in romanian and dutch and in
portuguese to my knowledge and our
members are continuing to add to them
but you can go down there and you can go
in the link and download these and use
them as you wish by the same token if
you can if people do create these sample
patterns and record them in different
languages I would be interested in
hearing about it because I would also
want to make these available to our
community at link so that somehow
collectively we can create this great
corpus as they like to say corpus of
sample sentences that are relatively
easy but represent examples of the basic
patterns in different languages and I
think that's a great way to begin in a
language with these basic patterns and
also a great way to regularly review the
grammar the basic structure yes I do
find myself reviewing some of the rules
and tables but I find it even more
useful to regularly review these basic
patterns by listening to them and
reading them so the key is to develop a
broad you know range of these basic
patterns in different languages I hope
some of you will be interested enough to
go to my blog and have a look and even
contribute some of these phrases or
sentences in your own language so there
you have it patterns recognizing
patterns as I've always felt intuitively
would seem to be the key to language
learning as if we if I understand
correctly the significance of the this
research in the Hebrew University in
Israel thank you for listening bye for
now